Hi, my name's Maciek Szymanski. I represent
African Alliance Investment Bank. Africa and
2010. I think it's definitely going to be
a big challenge to change perceptions about
Africa as the continent as a whole. What we
see is that Africa is often seen as a place
where things do not work. There are problems
with communications, technology, and also
offenders lack of man power. Btu in 2010 this
is great opportunity to South Africa and the
rest of the continent to show that such a
big event can be done on such a big scale.
What we have seen a number of countries actually
working together to making the 2010 world
cup and economic success. For example, in
Marshes, you have special packages available
when the fans can stay in the country if you
fly in for the games. We have also seen Botswana,
Zambia, and others hosting teams which will
be participating in the contest. I think that
over all this will be great benefits to the
region and to the continent as a whole. This
kind of show piece will hopefully change the
perceptions that many people in the world
have about the continent. Thank you.